a candidate for the Virginia House of
delegates has been discovered to have
regularly streamed lots of weird sex
stuff online for money and she didn't do
it way back in her Wayward youth many
many years ago she appears to have done
it pretty recently and with her husband
and we're not just talking about posing
for Playboy we're talking about real
depraved weird sex stuff now I am not
going to say what those weird sex things
are because this is a family show it's
very wholesome I'm also not going to say
her name because one it's ungentlemanly
two I don't want to promote her porn
business and three I don't want to
promote her campaign I actually don't
know which of those last two would be
worse now strange as the story is the
candidates response to the Revelation is
somehow even stranger she is accusing
the people who discovered her Myriad
porn videos of committing quote a sex
crime to attack her and her family she
says quote there is no line they won't
cross to silence women when they speak
up this is public porn this was not
revenge porn this wasn't some private
video or photos that some vindictive ex
decided to publish later this was This
Woman's very public prostitution
business every single video and picture
is something that she herself published
to the internet and the videos are not
just Private Matter they are politically
relevant because they show that there is
nothing that this woman won't do for
money they show that there is no higher
ideal that she serves Beyond temporal
pleasure and the almighty dollar you
can't even say that she's got a higher
ideal here of of upholding sex work as
this this great ideal of individual
self-expression or whatever because she
is rightly ashamed of the videos and
she's Furious that she now has to deal
with the consequences of her public
actions in other words and I don't mean
this as a cheap shot I mean this in a
true philosophical
sense this woman is the perfect liberal
politician I'm Michael nolles this the
Michael Nolls
[Music]
show
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meet at a secure price and 25
bucks off your order with my code nolles
K wle I had a delicious juicy good
Rancher steak just a few nights ago and
it was magnificent as always go to
goodranchers.com use code nolles today
Apple largest company on Earth is uh
worshiping mother Gaia in its new uh ad
for the new big announcement of products
uh we'll get to that in just a second
first though we're going to get all the
weird sex stuff out of the way early in
the show keep it wholesome around here
okay but I I just can't move on so
quickly from the world's two oldest
professions just coming back together
again and it's really not a cheap shot
when I say this is the perfect liberal
politician this this porn lady who is
now Furious that she has to deal with
the consequences of her actions I mean
it in the the real sense of liberalism
the point of liberalism Classical
liberalism modern liberalism is to do
away with ordinary political battles the
the promise of liberalism when it came
to the four 300 years ago was that
people are going to give up their deeply
held belief they're going to give up
Wars of religion they're going to give
up Wars of ideology they're going to
give up their Petty differences and
they're also going to give up their
higher ideals they're going to give up a
a sense of glory and nobility and honor
and they what they're going to give all
that up for is Commerce that we're going
to have a pluralistic society where
we're all members of different groups
I've got an allegiance to my church I've
got an allegiance to my bowling league
I've got an allegiance to my job but
we're we're not going to be too tied to
any of those things we are just going to
say that the only point of government is
to allow us all to trade peacefully and
accumulate private property and get more
stuff and that's it and then if we want
any meaning in our lives that meaning is
not going to be provided by the state
that meaning is not going to be polit
provided by the political Community
moving towards some goal or some
conception of the good and the true and
the Beautiful we're just going to have
to provide that for ourselves the the
only meaning we're going to find in our
lives is individual self expression
anything else would be authoritarian and
repressive and regressive and very much
not liberal that that is what the
liberal theorists themselves
increasingly over time said and that's
what this woman is doing she has taken
this uh degradation of the higher ideals
of politics and she's taken this
exaltation of Commerce and worshiping
Mammon to its logical conclusion and
that is she's going to degrade herself
into being a porn performer for
basically no reason This Woman's a nurse
practitioner I think her husband's a
lawyer I don't think they need the money
okay it's not like they're they're
trying to put a couple pennies together
to buy a loaf of bread they just wanted
to do this they have some weird fetish I
guess and and they were they're willing
to seduce men and run their pockets dry
to make a few pennies this is going to
happen a lot more often the the other
reason I mentioned this it's not because
of this house delegate race no one cares
about that in in Virginia it's because a
lot of people have been suckered into
this line of thinking to some degree or
another to degrading themselves for
money or for temporal pleasure to
sending naked pictures of themselves to
their boyfriend when they were 18 or
something to doing only fans to doing
whatever website this lady was on to
people we're in the internet age and
we're in an age without the traditional
moral strictures that have defined our
civilization which means you put those
two ingredients together and we're in an
age that does worship money so you put
those three ingredients
together there's a lot of dirt on people
okay and so we might say wow what a
crazy wild candidate expect more of this
there are going to be more and more
people who have done weird porn stuff
who enter politics because there's just
a much larger percentage of the
population that has has grown up it's
not even totally their fault has grown
up without the shame that was associated
with this and with a lot more
technological opportunity to do it now
before we move on from weird sex stuff
entirely we got to switch political
parties to Senator Kennedy one of the
great figures Senator Senator fog horn
Leghorn over at the capital
who during a senate hearing reads one of
the books that the Liberals are so upset
at having been banned from public
schools you you've heard this from the
Liberals those conservatives the those
authoritarians they're trying to ban
books from our schools and that's why
the children won't be exposed to the
these important works of literature well
here are the important works of
literature that the libs want to shove
down your kid's
throat all boys aren't
blue and I will quote from
it I put some lube on and got him on his
knees and I began
to from
behind I and kissed him while
he he asked me to turn over while he on
himself this was my and I I was
struggling to imagine
someone he got on top and slowly
inserted it was the worst pain I think I
have ever felt in my life eventually I
felt a mix of pleasure with the pain
close quote all boys aren't blue yeah I
sort of wish my producers had bleeped
out more of that that's unfortunate
but I'm I'm glad that we played it and
I'm glad that Senator Kennedy read this
the the Liberals the best reaction here
was from this liberal Aaron rupar who's
some lib journalist and he he tweets
that he goes Senator John Kennedy having
a very normal one during these Senate
hearings and he then he posts him
reading this
book hold on you're you're making fun of
John Kennedy you're saying it's it's
inappropriate you're insinuating that
it's inappropriate for John Kennedy to
read this in the
Senate that you want to read to students
to minors that you are whining about
being banned from schools this book
according to the publisher is suitable
for kids 15 years and up you think a
15-year-old should be reading that you
think a 15-year-old should be reading
that in school you think that only
15-year-olds are going to be reading
that if you put a book like that in
school first of all it's probably going
to be a sign to even at lower ages than
that did you ever watch a PG-13 movie
before you were 13 I think
so put it in the library of these
schools there are going to be kids in
that school who are 14 years old 13
years old by the way it's probably not
only going to be in the high schools
it's probably going to make it down to
the middle schools who knows how much
lower it's going to get so why did
Kennedy do this why did I even play this
disgusting clip on this show it was a
trap that Kennedy was setting Kennedy
read that book during the Senate hearing
to get the Aaron rupar of the world to
say what the hell's wrong with you
that's disgusting exactly that is
disgusting and what he's showing here
what Kennedy is showing here is
that the the idea that we have in our
head of what a book ban is and the
reality of what a book ban means in
practice in some high school or middle
school are very very different things we
living in our liberal
culture According to which the highest
and actually only moral edict is to just
do whatever you want as an individual we
believe that should never ban books
there's no there's nothing worse than a
book ban in in the modern liberal mind
and yet you look back through history
Plato supported book Banning and book
burning uh the apostles supported book
Banning and book burning the uh
Christians and westerners going all the
way up through the Middle Ages the
Scholastics supported book bands and
book burning even you get to the the
Protestant Revolution Martin Luther I'm
not the biggest Martin Luther guy in the
world but Martin Luther also supported
book Banning book bir you get all the
way up and and so you realize wait a
second how come so many people of
prominence many of whom were very
intelligent very serious people why did
they support certain restrictions on
what can be read in certain places well
because classrooms are like crystal
balls because your mind matters if you
if you just open your mind and your your
mind's eye up to Filthy disgusting
things all the time like whatever that
Virginia house delegate candidate was
doing or whatever whatever porn these
liberals want 12-year-olds to be reading
in school it's going to it's going to
mess up your mind it's going to mess up
your desires it's going to mess up your
ability to control your actions with
your rational will that's why they're
trying to do it and that's why serious
Statesmen and serious Educators for all
of history have said you got to be
careful about this and you can't just
have a totally open society as the
Liberals tell us to do you have to have
decent limits especially when we're
talking about education and Early
Education
because a third grade classroom is not
going to be the place where you debate
uh contentious matters of philosophy a
third grade classroom is where you are
taught as a matter of rote coercion
basic stuff to Tamp down your appetite
exercise your rational will and then
hopefully be able to resist this crap
when you become an adult and the libs
keep trying to force it on you we've got
to restore some balance to society got
to restore some balance of nature that's
why you got to go check out balance of
nature today right now go to balance ofn
nature.com use promocode noes living a
healthy life lifestyle is not always
easy especially when you're always on
the go you need simple manageable
routines to make sure you're getting the
proper nutrition every day that is why
I'm a huge fan of balance of nature
balance of nature fruits and veggies are
a great way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day their capsules are packed
with 100% whole food that you can take
at any time balance of nature uses a
cold vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption balance of nature sent
a bunch of their products down to the
studio for my team to try we all love
them make fruits and vegetables part of
your diet your body will thank you and
hopefully balance of nature will send
more products so these hyenas that steal
my balance of nature won't be able to
get all of them go to balanceof
nature.com use promo code NS kwes for 35
bucks off your first order as a
preferred customer balanceof nature.com
promo code nles kws for 35 bucks off
your first order balanceof nature.com
promo code s speaking of democrat
extremism kamla Harris insists that she
does not support no one no Democrat
supports abortion up until the moment of
birth that's a fake ridiculous
Republican talking point but then when
she's asked what limits she would place
on abortion she comes up
short what is it that you believe I mean
what week of pregnancy should abortion
access be cut off we need to restore the
protections of Rovers versus Wade we're
not trying to do something new well that
was nebulous because it was about
viability which could be anywhere
between 20 to 24 weeks and but so no no
no no no let let's let me be very clear
the Women's Health protection act that's
let let me be very
clear from day one the president has
been clear I have been clear we need to
put back the protections that are in
roie we into law Supreme that's not
clear that's not clear for the reason
that good on this journalist from CBS
for saying she says no no no it R Wade
was just a Supreme Court decision that
had an ambiguous uh uh limit on when one
could obtain an abortion and it varied
even with the development of uh modern
technology also roie Wade was a court
decision it was not a piece of
legislation so by definition if you're
going to pass a law that is something
new that is something different and
you're going to have to come to a more
precise ruling on when you would limit
abortion and K says no no no be boop
beep boop My Talking Point says go back
to roie Wade yeah but that obviously you
see how that's not possible because this
is a law and that was a court decision
and the court decision was ambiguous as
to what the limit would be so what's the
limit no I'm going to be really clear
but then she but then she won't be clear
keep going Court took it Congress has
the power and ability to pass
legislation to put those protections
back in line and Joe Biden will sign
that bill so that is what we want but
does it need to be specific in terms of
defining and where that guarantee goes
up to and where it does not at which
week of pregnancy we need to put back in
place the protections of Row versus way
we glitching question though because
we're not trying to but we're not trying
to do anything that did not exist before
June of a federal abortion law didn't
exist before so you are doing something
that's new no no but it's just Ro v Wade
yeah those are totally different things
involved in totally different branches
of government and actually the law that
you guys are trying to pass is totally
different and more radical even than
roie Wade so I don't
know I want to be as charitable as
possible and I think I am being as
charitable as possible when I say I
don't think kamla Harris knows anything
about pretty much anything so she might
just sincerely not understand that what
she's saying is not coherent or
intelligible she might also be
lying but I I want to give her the
benefit of the doubt and assume she just
is not all that intelligent or
knowledgeable and can't understand that
when you pass a new law that has never
existed before that is a new thing keep
going last year we it wasn't crafted
into law and that's why I'm asking you
for the specifics are because
Republicans say
the lack of a precise date in cutting it
off you know this they say that allows
Democrats to perform abortions up until
you know birth which is ridiculous
statistically not accurate it's ridicul
so now you see okay this is why the CBS
journalist is pushing so hard here a lot
of conservatives want to say wow good on
her she's a good journalist she's
actually speaking truth to power no no
no she just realizes Democrats have this
big vulnerability which is they support
abortion up until the moment of birth in
the case of the former Virginia governor
Ralph Northam they support abortion
after birth and so she knows this is a
big vulnerability she wants to help
Democrats by taking that talking point
off the table so she's serving up to
Kamala on a silver platter
hey come on man prove to me that this
isn't real look it's ridiculous it's
statistically insane what do you mean
statistically insane the law says you're
going to have an abortion up until the
moment of birth that's what the law
that's not that's not a lie that's not
statistically crazy that's not hyperbole
that's what the law says that's what
they did in New York that's what the
Virginia governor was pushing that's
what exists in a lot of places around
this country so that's real and and the
CBS journalist is saying please please
just disprove that and Comm says I know
it's ridiculous isn't it okay so what's
the limit
uh
mischaracterization of the point no the
point is the point need be more precise
I am being precise we need to put into
law the protections of Row versus weight
just total total gaslighting I I am
grateful to that CBS journalist because
even if I don't I don't want to try to
guess at her motives it would seem that
her motive is hey come on let's take
this anti-democrat talking point off the
table and Kamala just won't do it and
then she gaslights on top I am being
precise it's going to be something it's
going to be something and that something
is good speaking of the Biden
Administration Kevin McCarthy house
Republican leader has just come out and
finally after weeks of speculation he
has said they are going to open an
impeachment inquiry into Joe
Biden that's why today I am directing
our house committee to open a formal
impeachment inquiry into President Joe
Biden this logical Next Step will give
our committees the full power to gather
all the facts and answers for the
American public that's exactly what we
want to know the answers I believe the
president would want to answer these
questions and allegations as well this
effort will be led by chairman James
Comer at the committee on oversight in
coordination with chairman Jim Jordan
for Judiciary Committee and chairman
Jason Smith on ways and
means now I do not make this decision
lightly and regardless of your party or
who you voted for these facts should
concern all Americans
the American people deserve to
know that the public offices are not for
sale and that the federal government is
not being used to cover up the actions
of a
politically Associated family all true
this is a smart thing to do it will keep
Biden a little bit on his heels
hopefully get us a little bit more
information about Biden keep the story
of Biden's corruption in the news if
nothing else the best argument against
Biden's impeachment of course is kamla
Harris you saw on display right there in
that interview with CBS she has got
nothing Joe Biden seems like he is a
roads scholar compared to uh Kamala and
Joe Biden obviously is not quickest on
his feet either we can say this is
because Biden's scile we can say this is
because kamla Harris is not particularly
smart but I I want to be nicer to kamla
here and and to Biden for that matter
when kamla can't answer what the limit
is on the Democrat view of abortion
that's because there isn't one and there
can't be one The Logical conclusion of
the Democrat view on abortion is that
women should be able to murder their
children up until at least the moment of
birth there's no limiting principle
because from the moment of conception a
baby is alive and a baby is human there
is nothing that changes other than the
natural development of that baby but
there's if if human life has any
sanctity to it if if innocent human life
has any uh right to not be killed then
it has that from the moment that it
begins and so it's it's not just that
kamla is a weak politician it's not just
that she hasn't thought through her view
she probably has thought through her
view and she realizes that there is no
point at which she can say this is going
to be the limit that that is going to
make any sense as a matter of bioethics
and two that's going to appease her base
because her base is is further even than
the politicians tend to be Hillary tried
to walk this line by saying abortion
should be safe legal and rare that
didn't work that fell apart because the
Bas recognizes that ideas have
consequences the consequences of the
idea that a woman should be able to
murder her child is that a woman should
be able to murder her child when she
feels like it and so that's a ghastly
view it's why the Democrats have to hide
it and if you have to hide your in
public that should at least some of the
time make you wonder huh Are My Views
good is what I believe a good thing or
is it evil now you want to talk about a
really good thing that's good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com use
promo code nolles I just adore good
ranchers our team is constantly talking
about delicious all- American Meat you
know what they like even more when that
American meat is free that's one of the
the reasons that these guys love good
ranchers they Source the best meat in
America deliver it to your door even
better right now they're offering two
years of free ground beef to anyone who
subscribes that is a
$480 value not only are you going to get
the best cuts of meat from a trusted
100% American Source company you're also
going to lock in your price for two
whole years when you subscribe to any of
their boxes that is two years of free
highquality ground beef in a locked in
price no other Meat Company guarantees
anything like that you should get it
right now I don't actually know how the
finances work on this how they can
afford to do it it's just the best and
especially with the ground beef you're
getting the best burgers I've ever had
in my entire life you're getting steak
that is absolutely out of this world
every single cut of it you can get the
chicken you can get the pork I just
freaking love this company and I eat it
multiple times a week and if you're not
if you're not eating it you should be I
when I was a kid steak was like a very
rare special treat and the notion that
you could just get great steak now
basically whenever you want is money
mindblowing go to goodranchers.com today
use code NES for $25 off and free ground
be for 2 years subscribe to any box to
lock in your price on America's best
meat for two whole years
goodranchers.com use code nolles for
over 500 bucks in savings subscribe to
good ranchers American Meat
delivered I've told you time and time
again I hate to say it it pains
me but don't say I didn't tell you so
yes or no the game has sold out I said
it was sell out it's sold out over at
dailywire.com
shop it will come back into stock
however we got we order these things and
they sell out immediately if you want
this game for your Halloween parties if
you want this game for Thanksgiving if
you want this game for Christmas to give
to your friends or play with your family
get it now if you already have the
classic game be sure to get the all new
conspiracy theory expansion pack in time
for spooky season speaking of by the way
my collection in the rapidly approaching
change of seasons if you are even mildly
familiar with this show you might be
aware of my automnal Affinity for a
certain seasonal treat I am an offici AO
of the PSL the pumpkin spice latte I am
a basic white girl from September 1st up
through the beginning of winter so what
better way to bring the fall atmosphere
into your home than with the allnew
Michael nolles pumpkin spice candle I
call it the pumpkin sple NS candle it's
wonderful it's filled with M cinnamon
maybe a little vanilla m some nice
pumpkin spice it's available now in my
collection uh this is going to sell out
if it hasn't sold out already I think it
may have but but we've got more coming
in uh order order it right now if you
want it it's delicious it's lovely a
nice little nice little label on it it's
very very seasonal
the.com
shop speaking of Joe
Biden I don't know if you stay up at
night I stay up because I'm reading and
smoking cigars but some people stay up
because they're afraid of things you
know they might be afraid of how to pay
the bills they might be afraid of all
the attacks on our children they might
be attack uh they might be afraid of the
American political order fraying they
might be afraid of War even nuclear war
but Joe Biden says no none of that is
frightening compared with the terror of
climate
change in addition to helping the
environment overall and the only
existential threat Humanity faces even
more frightening than a than nuclear war
is global warming going above 1.5° in
the next 20 10
years we it' be real trouble there's no
way back from that are you more
frightened of global warming than you
are of nuclear war I'm not particularly
frightened of either but I would say
nuclear war is a more frightening
Prospect and yet if you're listening to
this show you're probably going to make
fun of this you say what kind of stupid
dummy is terrified of climate change
a fair number of people I know people I
have friends from New York who say I
don't know if I'm going to have a child
because you know climate change they'll
grow up in a world with the rising sea
levels and The Apocalypse oragon of
tsunamis and whatever else is predicted
the sun monster coming down and they'll
also say and if we have more children
that'll contribute to climate change but
people really believe this they really
believe this is the threat to humanity
even more than nuclear war it reminds me
of a line from the founder of anarchism
Pierre Joseph prudon who says that
whoever invokes Humanity wants to cheat
it people do this in politics a lot
especially in Liberal politics but if
you say I'm fighting on behalf of
humanity you're cheating that's not how
politics works in
politics people are divided into
different sides at the level of domestic
politics it's the Republicans and the
Democrats the left and the right at the
level of international politics it's the
Americans versus the Russians or versus
the
Chinese or Iraq versus Iran but there's
always a concrete enemy and they're
they're always concrete political allies
and friends when you get to the the
level of humanitarian politics
where you say we're all it's all just
we're citizens of the world man just
coming together you know what you're
really saying is that we're going to get
rid of politics this is something that
the Liberals have tried to do this is
what fukuyama means when he says that
we've reached the end of History the
meaning of that phrase is that Politics
as we have known it for all of recorded
history that will cease to exist the
antagonisms the divisions the wars
that's going to go away and we're all
just going to kind of give give up our
deeply held beliefs and get together for
the purpose of free trade and the
accumulation of material wealth but
that's not how human beings work we're
drawn to more than that cheap Chinese
stuff is not enough to inspire and
sustain A Life That's why when we've
achieved this alleged liberal Utopia
what do people start to do they start
doing a bunch of drugs and weird sex
stuff and killing themselves and the
life expectancy actually decreases and
birth rates decrease and the
civilization starts to die this is not
how human beings are meant to live we
are the political animal as Aristotle
says and we we live in political Society
so one trick one trick that the liberal
politicians try to use to allow politics
to continue even when we're talking
about all this humanitarian we're all
together Kumbaya kind of stuff is they
have to just invent an enemy and not an
enemy within the human species but an
enemy outside of it so they'll say no no
no we're all United because we're
fighting climate change that's the big
enemy we we just observed the
anniversary of 911 what do people always
say about
9/11 well it was this horrible horrible
day but the one silver lining in that
awful storm cloud was we all came
together we'd never been so United I
don't remember having Unity like that
before everybody says it and they're
right we had a very clear enemy you saw
the face Osama Bin Laden that was the
clear enemy that United all of the
American people in order to be United
you have to have a clear sense of who
your enemy is and in Liberal politics
where we refuse to say that any people
are actually the enemy we say oh it's
it's climate change it's the sun monster
it's something else it's something
outside of us but that that in itself is
a highly
political operation because what that
means then is the people who contribute
to global warming they're the worst
enemies of all they're much worse
enemies than Osama Bin Laden they're
much worse enemies than Stalin or Mau or
Hitler even they're much worse enemies
because their enemy is not just some
country or some particular type of
people but but their enemy is all of
humanity and so ironically the
humanitarian liberal politics which
which purports to to usher in an age of
Peace where we all just kind of love
each other that ends up being the
cruestv colored hair who say hey man
peace and love be kind be kind to
everybody just be really they're always
the crest people who ostracize members
of their family who shriek horrible OB
ities who threaten to kill people who
show up to my speeches and throw
explosives at the wall it it's always
those people and it seems like there's a
contradiction there but there isn't
really they they have convinced
themselves that they're standing up for
all of humanity and it just so happens
that the people they disagree with cease
to be human or they forfeit their
Humanity because they have made
themselves the enemy of all of humanity
and you see this especially especially
when it comes to climate change
Apple biggest company in the world has
just had its big annual Apple event
where we're unveiling the new products
and the new technologies and Tim Cook
did this by opening the show with a skit
that he had filmed in which he is
accountable to Mother
Earth Mother Nature Mother Nature
welcome to Apple how how was the weather
getting
in
the weather was however I wanted it to
be let's cut to the chase in 2020 you
promised to bring Apple's entire carbon
footprint to Zero by 2030 Henry David
the row over
here said we have a profound opportunity
to build a more sustainable future for
the planet we share I think our 10:00
said the same thing they all do all
right this is my third corporate
responsibility gig today so who wants to
disappoint me first well we've got some
updates we're excited to share with you
materials status is there a materials
person here yes we are in the process of
eliminating all plastic from our
packaging by the end let me guess 50
years from now when someone else is left
holding the bag by the end of next year
actually oh wow and it goes on and on
and on we'll cut it off there I
can't this
is e exhibit
375,000
that our civilization is returning to a
pagan kind of public
religion this is just the opposite of
Christianity Tim Cook is sitting there
and he's going to be accountable to that
higher power that rules over him and
what is that higher power is that higher
power God no it's a nature
Spirit we see in the Bible as people
begin to become aware of the one true
God the Lord Our God the distinction
between the true God and all the fake
Gods is that all the fake gods that
people worship they're just kind of
nature Spirits they're they're lower
worldly kind of entities God himself is
outside of the world he created the
world he is the unmoved Mover he is he
is perfectly himself and then he in an
act of Love creates everything including
the world and he says don't worship
worldly things don't become worldly but
look to the things of the
spirit what does Apple say here no no no
we're just going to worship literally
the world we're literally going to
worship mother nature and why are we
going to do that well because we want to
make sure that in this fleshy
terrestrial life we get to keep
appeasing the spirits of the sky
the spirits of the the oceans the
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in high places and we don't
even notice it most people are going to
watch that if you're listening to this
show you probably are a little uh more
in tune with with the underlying message
of this kind of propaganda but most
people are going to watch it they say oh
that's kind of cute haaha Mother Nature
is uprating the CEO of Apple T okay
whatever moving on and you don't
recognize that the kind of understanding
of human nature and religion that's
being presented here is the exact
opposite of the religion that built our
entire civilization but but also that
this is the normal kind of religion that
exists has existed most places on Earth
for most of the history of the world
other other than after the Incarnation
this is this is normal paganism and as
our country and our culture is giving up
Christianity we're just returning to
that we're doing the same thing that the
Canaanites used to do we're worshiping
nature and we're sacrificing our
children to to appease our false gods
that's what we're doing and and there's
nothing new Under the Sun and we we
think that we're very modern and
scientific and Innovative and we're not
we're
just we're either going to choose good
things that have been around for a long
time or we're going to choose bad things
that have been around for a long time
now speaking of false religions and
powers of the air did you see the story
I have to get to it because I know Walsh
is going to get to it and he's going to
spread his ridiculous propaganda so I've
got to get to it there's a story coming
out of Mexico that
[Music]
ufologists have presented to the
Mexican
authorities
mummified UFO ET corpses and you look at
the corpses and they look like little I
don't know terracotta figures or
something they look like little little
stonework that some eccentric would have
around his garden and they they purport
to they look just like ET I mean like
actually from the Steven Spielberg movie
and they say these are the bodies of
aliens and see that's not it's not human
DNA and it's not a human shape it's an
alien and to me it looks like someone
just carved this out of cement but they
say no no that's an alien now there's a
little bit of important context here I'm
going to pull this up because this is
the part that Walsh is not going to read
on his
show you can you can read the whole
article everyone's going to be saying
this is proof that aliens exist well
here we have let's
see here we have a key quote from this
article the claims by the self-claimed
ufologist have not been proven the
claims about the DNA the claims about
this not being recognizable as human or
made by humans they have not been proven
and Mr mouson has previously been
associated with claims of discoveries
that have later been
debunked
so it's just fake guys it's fake because
aliens are just demons for liberals and
atheists that's all it is it's just
maybe a scop to distract us from actual
pressing political matters um and
religious matters or maybe it's demonic
in nature or maybe it's just some weirdo
who got fooled but the headline you're
going to see is alien bodies discovered
and the actual story is guy who made
disproven claims makes more similarly to
be disproven claims that's that is
what's going on here now speaking of
unidentified life forms Tim Scott claims
to have a girlfriend this is the uh
Senator Republican senator from South
Carolina who's running for president and
he made the claims on cable news and a
lot of people are making fun of him for
these claims I'm not going to make fun
of him for these claims regardless of
whether or not they are true we'll get
to that in one second first though
despite the lackluster economy the daily
wire is thriving not not only that we
are hiring we are currently looking for
an inside sales rep to join our fast
growing sales department as an inside
sales rep you will identify and solicit
new client Direct business this is a
unique opportunity to engage with
clients Nationwide to discuss
advertising opportunities across
multiple platforms including podcast
display email video and more the
position is based in Asheville Tennessee
if you're interested in joining our team
visit dailywire.com careers that is
dailywire.com careers
today my favorite comment yesterday is
from slap my base 38 who says the fact
that this video My Episode yesterday was
deleted and had to be re-uploaded means
that Michael's show was spicier than a
PSL with extra cinnamon so true spicier
perhaps even than this candle I noticed
that some people were were tagging me
they said Michael the show went up late
on YouTube yesterday which to me says
first of all you should join daily wire
you should become a daily wire plus
member then you get the show immediately
live no YouTube censorship whatsoever we
talk about whatever we want but two yeah
sometimes it's got to come down because
YouTube is looking for any excuse to
Nuke my channel and so uh they've
they've got to uh clean it up for
YouTube and we always we always point
out what we're what we're cleaning up
you know okay this segment had to go
YouTube was going to Nuke our Channel
sorry this word had to go so you got to
go get it at mnol show on X formerly
known as Twitter or dailywire plus Tim
Scott says he has a
girlfriend uh here is the
claim and this headline you might have
caught your attention GOP donors are
privately
pushing to Senator Tim Scott to give
more details about his private life your
single status so you must have heard
this and you got to be ATT tuned without
donations without support you can't run
what is your
status well obviously uh at this point
I'm taking I have a wonderful girlfriend
and uh we have a wonderful relationship
the good news is uh God has blessed me
with a smart Christian woman that that's
great news but more importantly is why
are are the headlines there the
headlines are there because as I ride
eyes in the polls as people show up at
my My Town Halls it scares even my
opponents okay this is the a similar
story that happened with Corey Booker
last time Corey Booker also US senator
who wasn't married who had never really
been linked with any
girlfriends uh and and then right as he
starts writing for president Cory Booker
starts dating an actress it was a little
on the nose to to cast an actress and he
was a little more open about talking
about this alleged relationship he was
having than Tim Scott seems to be and so
some people are saying oh Tim Scott it's
just fake he doesn't really have a
girlfriend you know his girlfriend's up
in Canada she goes to another school or
something uh I don't care I'm not going
to make fun of Tim Scott for this I
don't care if Tim Scott has a girlfriend
or not I don't care about the reasons
for for which Tim Scott may or may not
have a girlfriend it doesn't it doesn't
interest me not everyone is called to be
married that is the norm that is true
for most people but for some people
they're called to religious life they're
called to a different vocation they're
called to a consecrated singleness some
people want to get married and it's just
never happened I don't I don't judge on
that kind of thing you know as long as
one is doing what one ought to do as
long as one is doing the right thing
then the actual circumstances in which
one finds
oneself with or without a wife in some
other kind of vocation remaining
celibate doing whatever it's fine by me
I don't care and it reminds me forget
about Tim Scott for a
second Christians get a a bad rap for
being judgmental because we say Hey you
know you shouldn't have like weird porno
in elementary schools you know we're
really judgmental we're we're so
authoritarian but but Christians do have
that w we have thoughts about uh
personal comportment about professional
morality political morality sexual
morality we have we we have a view of
how the human life ought to be lived as
does everybody by the way some people
are just a little more forthright about
it than others but in that way
Christians are very
judgmental but then in the extreme cases
it seems to me Christians and
conservatives and there's sub
substantial overlap there are the least
judgmental people on
earth and the supposedly tolerant
open-minded inclusive liberals they're
the most judgmental people on Earth
because in the extreme cases let's say
some guy becomes an Axe
Murderer let's say some guy I don't know
engages in some other sort of terrible
Behavior what the Christian response is
is oh well there but for the grace of
God go go I oh yeah that yeah we're this
is human nature the imagination of man's
heart is evil from the beginning we're
inclined towards sin we're born with
original sin we we have to deal with
concupisent and yeah thank thanks to the
grace of God that I haven't fallen that
way but I easily could have I'm no
better than that guy of my own uh Merit
I just have had the good grace to be uh
brought off that
path and so I I know the Liberals are
are going to be the ones who make fun of
Tim Scott for this it's not really going
to be the conservatives maybe make make
a few jokes here or there but it's
always the Liberals they're going to be
the ones saying this guy can't get a
girl or this guy's gay or this guy's
that or this guy's they're going to be
the ones insinuating all sorts of mean
nasty little things about him uh I think
most conservatives are going to say okay
whatever Tim Scott are you going to be a
good president or not he's he's not all
that high in the polls right now so you
know it doesn't look like he's going to
win the nomination but if he doesn't win
the nomination it's not going to be
because he's got a girlfriend or doesn't
have a girlfriend or because those
conservatives are so damned judgmental
now speaking of relationships a couple
days ago she's 26 was trending and she's
26 was trending because Chris Evans who
is an insufferably liberal actor he
played one of the superheroes uh he's 41
and uh he's married this G who's 26 her
name is Alba Baptista it's a good name
and this was trending this she's only 26
what a
creep all these liberal accounts oh it's
awful how look at that age Gap he's 15
years older than she is that's a she
he's exploiting her and I thought hold
on wait a second wait a
second you're telling me that a
26-year-old woman cannot really consent
to marry a man who's a little bit older
than her but a 16-year-old
[Music]
girl does that make any sense of course
that doesn't make any sense so what
explains it what explains it is not some
consistent view of consent what explains
it is not some consistent view of
morality what explains it is that
whatever is good
these liberals will
oppose and sounds like I'm being a
little bit harsh but I'm not show me the
lie show me the counter example what
explains this is when a woman marries a
man they enter into the basic political
institution that is conducive to both of
their flourishing and that is open to
the possibility of life and that can
create more children but the libs don't
want that anything that will break up
marriages anything that will reduce the
number of children being born anything
that will reduce people's true
flourishing and happiness anything that
will
undermine Justice and the political
order the Liberals will support even if
th those various uh facets of their
project seem to be in conflict with one
another that's what it's about and the
reason is that they're beginning from
flawed premises about human nature and
the point of life and they're uh they
allow this to develop into behavior that
is very harmful to themselves and to
others and they follow these bad ideas
to their logical conclusions that's why
this is why when people bemoan tribal
politics yes you don't want to be
thoughtlessly partisan yes you don't
want to blindly follow some Mob Of
course not but broadly speaking tribal
politics is a pretty good thing and
tribal politics by the way is all
politics because politics is about real
particular groups that are in opposition
to one another and
so we say well we don't we don't want to
be tribal or anything like that look if
you agree with a group of people of a
lot of people on 99% of issues and
there's one issue on which you think you
disagree I think any degree of humility
would make you stop and wonder huh am I
wrong here is it that all of these
people who agree with me on so many
things that they happen to be wrong on
this one issue or is it possible that I
am wrong on this issue as as a rule of
thumb tribal politics is not a bad thing
we actually just call it Politics the
rest of the show continues now folks it
is woke Wednesday you do not want to
miss it become a member use code nolles
at check out for two months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans